qui me dit à l'antenne surprise pour
vous petite surprise mais surprise vidéo
ah oui mais bon je vous dit peut-être
mon alimentation
sauf que c'était parce que c'est moderne
tard un conteur hors pair qui vous
mènera une vidéo il est rugueux pour
vous ou alors on lance un vidéo on peut
la lance et je prends merci fait
plusieurs trucs
deux informations
[Musique]
je suis heureux de vous présenter cette
émission consacrée à celui que l'on
appellera longtemps le plus grand roi du
monde
voici tirer même humain l'homme et le
roi
le jeune monarque donne des
divertissements somptueux des bosquets
perry et des bassins animé par des jeux
d'eau spectaculaires jamais on a vu un
tel événement dans la mémoire des hommes
on va parti faire un barbecue au château
de versailles et il sait que le moindre
de ses gestes la moindre de ses paroles
ont des répercussions politiques autour
de lui
maintenant qu'il gouverne seul le
pouvoir organise son ascension que rien
ni personne ne semble pouvoir arrêter
continue à me charrier vous aurez quand
je serai plus là vous verrez comme
jusqu'à